Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
My name is David Flanagan,
although I also go by the hand of
Rawkode.
Go figure. And today is the launch of
our third course at the academy, and we're
taking a look at BGP.
BGP is a a really cool technology
that probably does provide the foundation of scaling
your applications to the edge and globally.
Alright.
For today's first session, we're doing things a
little bit different, and we do have a
guest. I can't find my mic.
There we go. And if you enable that
option where you kinda spiral it around and
it goes pulsedly big, but, anyway, that's for
another day. Yeah. We're doing things a little
bit differently. I'm John Beck's
friend and former colleague,
Jeremy Tanner.
Hey. How's it going?
Not bad at all. Good afternoon to you.
Good morning to me.
Alright. Well, I mean, thank you for joining
me today. It's nice that we get to
do something together. You know, full disclosure, Jeremy
and I worked together at Equinix. So we
have done plenty of streams together. We met
up recently in Austin, which was awesome.
But I was in
CD con. So nice
to see you again.
Yeah. Absolutely.
I am
I'm ready to hear more about about
BGP and BGPN
and Equinix Medal. I got up Well, I
was gonna say got some coffee, but first,
I went and looked and I was like,
do the thing that everyone needs to do,
which is
follow Rawkode Academy on LinkedIn. All of the
socials.
All of the socials. Like, that's where the
stream needs to go.
But, you know, for so long And then
coffee. Yeah. Yeah.
For so long, I've always just streamed to
YouTube.
But I think for course material, I wanna
push it a bit broader and wider,
especially as what I'm saying is I'm having
to update some of the older videos, and
YouTube really doesn't like it when you have
to do that. We're gonna just digress though
for the first five minutes.
So what I wanna do is just, you
know, livestream it to multiple places. We're out
on LinkedIn. We're out on Twitter. We're out
on YouTube.
And then what we'll do is I'm gonna
edit this back. I'm gonna stick it on
Vimeo, and I'm gonna make it a web
available on the new Rawkode Academy website, which
will be launching next week. So trying to
do things a little bit differently as I've
done for the last eighteen months and just
experiment. And
yeah, this is the first course I'm gonna
do it with, but it should be good.
Alright. Perfect. Back on topic. For anyone who
is not familiar
with you, can you just give us the
TLDR of who is Jeremy Tanner?
Excellent.
I like motorcycles and mountains, and I have
two small copies of myself, but you're probably
really looking for,
have been helping people understand bare metal and
bare metal accessories at Equinix Metal. Inside Equinix,
the world's digital infrastructure company, and now,
based in Austin, Texas.
And, yeah, certainly open to questions,
meeting new friends, and and today hearing about
BGP.
Yeah. I mean, I hope you're prepared to
slide because I haven't.
Uh-oh.
Well, here's my first favorite feature of LinkedIn
streaming.
LinkedIn user says hello there. Hello, LinkedIn user.
I'm assuming we don't get that name on
the API,
but we do have the regulars. We have
no hey, no.
Russell.
Hey, Russell.
Another LinkedIn user saying LinkedIn is slow on
the uptake. Well, yeah, they don't have username.
So I guess that'll come in the future.
That's a premium feature.
Stefan,
human.
Hello to both. It's all very kind.
A good morning from Steve. Hey, Steve. Alright.
So people must be wondering. The LinkedIn user
is Chris. Well, yes. LinkedIn users, if you
are watching, feel free to stick your name
and a colon at the start of every
message, which is pretend that that's gonna work
for today.
Know there's too many comment. I'm okay. I'm
only gonna show two more comments. We're we're
gonna stop BGP now. Please tell us about
more cycles. Yeah. We will be getting another
stream for that. I I reckon Jeremy could
go on for a while. Cool.
Alright. How does this course work? Well, much
like the other two courses, if you go
to the Rawkode Academy, Github page at github.com/rockwoodacademy,
there is a courses page.
As you'll see, we have our influx DB,
our Telco course, and our global reach with
BGP.
Now, of course, we're going to be spinning
up some bare metal for this course so
that we can actually use BGP and route
traffic to it. So this is not like
the other courses where
you could just run a container with the
software. Unfortunately,
BGP requires hardware and other stuff, but it
is invaluable
to learn. So we have with Equinix metal
a code
here
of Rawkode,
really difficult to remember.
But if you go to the Equinix metal
website by clicking the link,
you can click get started
twice.
And there's a coupon code thing here. Let
me make that bigger.
It's like Rawkode in that box, fill in
the rest of your details. No credit card
is required, and you'll get $200.
I just clicked my browser. Oh, it's alright.
You get $200
of credit. So that $200 is going to
do you well.
I'm just gonna go to the console now.
We'll get you $200 of credit. I think
you can get
four hundred hours of compute for that. I
think the c three smalls are about 50¢
an hour. Jeremy can correct me if he
wishes.
So, yeah, four hundred hours for you to
experiment with.
Yeah. Most recently variable depending on where you
are, more in some places, less in others,
but more for larger machines, less for smaller,
but
certainly in that ballpark.
Alright.
Can't believe I closed that window.
See, I I was saying just before we
went live, I I I was considering a
3PM coffee. I feel like I made the
wrong decision by not having that coffee. Well,
we're gonna move on.
Okay. So step one well, step one is
sign up. Use the coupon. Make sure you
get those credits. And now today, we're gonna
do the first two parts of this course.
So we're gonna do a bit of a
conversation between Jeremy and I where we talk
about what is BGP,
how the written works, all the stuff that
you kinda need to know before you start
deploying it.
And then in the latter part of the
stream, we'll actually do our first BGP deployment.
So we will deploy multiple servers in multiple
regions.
And what we're gonna show you is how
the routing works, the latency is kept low,
and this is how you scale your application
globally
or to use that wonderful word of the
moment edge
or at least as close to the edge
as we're gonna get.
Alright. Introduction to BGP.
Yeah. Just absolute cop out here. Right? Just
stick in the Wikipedia definition
and then just ask people to read it.
I actually read the Wikipedia definition. I was
like, that is super complicated.
Like, does that really tell people what BGP
is? Is that for people that already know
BGP, but what primer?
Like, for people that don't know BGP,
it's just it really I I don't think
it's that great. However, what I did know,
here's a cool trick. Are you aware of
Wikipedia Simple? I assume you are.
No. No. I've not run across it. Alright.
So you can do Wikipedia.
Let's just go to the BGP page. Right?
And sometimes you just get all this nonsense
and you're like, border gateway protocols, the standardized
exterior gateway protocol to send to exchange written
blah blah blah blah. Right? Doesn't always help
you. Right? Especially when you get into more
some of the more, like, complicated mathematical or
physics topic,
which I randomly do because I just get
too curious. But you can swap out the
language,
e n,
for simple.
And usually, it's not great in this case,
but usually,
you get a very simplified definition of the
thing that you're looking at. That's a cool
wee trick.
There's also a Scots language one, but I
doubt there's a Scots language for
BGP.
Oh, does it have to be localized into
simple?
I don't know what I did there. Is
that just simple to okay. Oh, yeah. Hold
on.
I replaced too much. So simple counts simple
counts as a language Yeah. And just like
French, Italian, or Scots. Okay. Well, apparently, Scots
doesn't work in. But there is a Scots
version.
There.
Small digression again. I suspect that's why I
don't have I'm not joined by people. It's
too easy for us to go down another
path.
But a comment there from Pavan, today I
learned Wikipedia is simple. Yeah. It's a cool
trick, especially for those more complicated things. Glad
I could help.
Okay. So rather than I was reading in
verbatim that Wikipedia description, people can read it
if they want. I figured you and I
could just talk about what problem does BGP
actually solve. Like, people are here because they
wanna learn the technology,
but they probably wanna learn it because they
have a problem to solve. And I figured
we could just kind of roughly
explain that. And what I've done in this
README document is try
to in a simple fashion,
describe what happens when you request a website
on a browser. So maybe we can just
kinda go over this so we can add
extra flavor details to better on how we
feel. Good to go?
Sure.
Cool.
So what I've said here is let's consider
what happens when a request for a website
is made from your machine.
This is high level. I know that people
get asked this and, like, interview questions, and
people have failed it because they didn't talk
about electrons and electricity and all that stuff.
I guess interview people, they take it too
far. I just said you need to do
it in three steps. I probably failed the
Amazon interview or whoever asked this. But first,
we got a DNS request. So when we
type in console.equinox.com,
Google Com, whatever,
those
words really mean nothing to the Internet. What
we need to do is the DNS lookup
to get some sort of IP address, which
is how all the magic of Internet work.
Our browser
will then send an HTTP request to the
IP address,
and it uses a host header. I don't
know why I included that detail.
I mean, it's correct, but, you know, probably
not pertinent to this conversation.
However,
that server will eventually respond back with some
HTML or browser renders it, and then you're
happy.
Alright. Jeremy, how does the Internet work?
So the the first thing I would like
so the IP given by the DNS
the IP address given by the DNS system,
first of all, can be one of multiple
IP addresses, but you can't
which one is given isn't determined by on
any sort of basis. It can be, it
can be either at random or semi random,
but you're not, I don't think you're segmenting
by, by anything there.
Additionally,
I suppose it's important to say that you
need to be able to reach your
your DNS server,
and your DNS server
is in your settings as an IP address.
So how do you make the DNS request
to the DNS server
at the DNS' IP address?
Well, things just got made up very quickly.
Yeah. I think, actually,
it before we're this is actually part
three of the courses where we're gonna implement
our our own globally distributed kind of DNS
lookup. We won't go into that in too
much detail. But you're right. Your DNS server
has an IP address, and we have to
route that and answer that as quickly as
possible and keep our latency low. So it's
a really good use case for BGP.
Alright. What waffles I have next? That's me.
Oh, yeah. There's a lot of DNS servers.
Your ISP is gonna bunch have a couple.
It's all distributed. It's all cached, all this
other stuff.
And then I include some latency figures.
Alright.
These figures I got from
wonder network,
which is a really cool website I wasn't
familiar with,
But you can actually add all your own
cities, which I thought was nice.
You're
in Austin.
Yep. I'm in Glasgow.
I don't know if there'll be a Glasgow.
I guess we'll do London.
And there we can drop Barcelona.
Don't know why I'm going through all this
effort just to show our ping times, but
you know.
There we go.
So not bad considering,
you know, our connections are governed by the
laws of physics and the speed of light,
a connection latency between our two cities is
only a hundred and eighteen milliseconds.
Very good.
Make can make that error so slightly larger?
Know. The
monitor is small. I'm not sure what sort
of sort of death star readout there is
in a Oh, you can right click on
it and control and then full screen it
if you want. I should have touched that
before we went live. But yeah.
So I didn't easy mode. That's good. So
I sent this website
just while I was putting stuff together for
this course. And it's a really good way
to understand the latency between you and your
customers.
And let's talk about latency. Latency is just
the
amount of time that is required for all
requests
to happen. So while the latency of a
hundred and eighteen milliseconds seems quite small,
if your web page is making tens, hundreds,
thousands, tens of thousands of connections to resources,
at least when the connection has to be
opened, etcetera,
It can add up really, really quickly,
which is why, you know, if you Google
for why does Australia have slow Internet,
it's because all the products that they're using
are in San Francisco and Europe, etcetera. So,
you know, maybe the I'm sure there are
lots of Australian data centers, but we all
use products from American companies and and European
companies as well. So they notoriously
have quite bad speeds with some of our
services,
which is why we need to decrease that
latency.
You can see London to New York is
only 70.
LA and Austin are around that mark. Tokyo
and then Sydney. So it just keeps growing
again, but it is governed by the law.
Is that best case or worst case?
So so the so a lot of those
were maybe, like, IBX to IBX or data
center to data center more so than
you're going to probably have more hops in
there depending on if you're
resident on a residential Internet plan or your
business or whatever. It's unlikely that you're right
in the data center where, where those pages
or services are hosted. Yeah. We've not even
talked about hops.
You know, when we do some trace routes
later, we can definitely break that down. But
to answer your question,
it looks like this website does 30 pings
to the destination.
It displays the average,
and then it's got some extra scores for
lowest average ping, etcetera. So the details are
there
if you really, really wanna get into it.
What
this means that I think, you know, I
think what I'm trying to highlight I mean,
I wrote the damn doc. I should know
what I'm highlighting. But is that if you
want if you're building a product that is
global scale and that means customers and and
and users of your service, then you need
to improve the performance of people and the
farthest parts from your servers.
And that just means deploying to more locations,
but not just deploying to more locations is
that you then have to be able to
route the traffic to those locations when the
customers are in those locations. Like, you don't
wanna go to a central location and then
redirect them, which
we used to see a lot
in the twenty tens, early '20 tens is
that you would go to not gonna say
Google. I don't think they ever did this,
you know, Yahoo or something. You go to
Yahoo.com and then you're redirected to eu.Yahoo.co.uk
or whatever like that. And that was all
just handled that way. So that was a
simple way of doing it. BGP is is
much nicer solution.
Alright.
So
yeah. Well, that's why we have CDNs. Now
I'm assuming anyone watching this course is probably
familiar with a CDN.
The idea being that, you know, we host
static websites as an example on s three
bucket
or even just NGINX servers, but then we
stick something in front of it, like Cloudflare,
CloudFront, Fastly.
There are others.
They cache all of those stuff. Those have
their proxies running in many, many locations around
the world.
And
your customers help them instead of your centralized
server and proven their performance.
And how these CDNs work is all BGP.
Go figure.
The third part no. The fourth part of
this course is we will be implementing and
building our own CDN.
So after today, we'll do our own DNS
servers with BGP. We'll build our own CDN
with BGP.
And the last part of this course will
be building our own edge functions,
so your own edge Lambda
product
using BGP as well.
Anything you wanna add?
I don't think so. The
yep. CDN's good. CDN's closer to CDN's
closer to user.
And,
yes, I mean, I ran into this when,
I think we ran into each other previously
in,
in Spain during conference time, and
I was having really having
a really slow time because I was using
the VPN that's in California, which is not
close to which is not close to Spain
at all. And so if I I switched
it for the week to to Madrid, all
good again.
Cool.
Alright. The last part of this document before
we actually do something interesting
with this is just to kinda talk about
how BGP work. So
when we want to send a request to
an IP address,
we
the Internet, the mystical Internet, has to route
that traffic for you.
What typically happens is your browser makes a
request to your ISP.
I was in the ISP. There's likely an
autonomous system. Autonomous systems
are
essentially
that
know how to route traffic within their own
network, but they do this based on prefixes.
So
we got an example here as this router
or autonomous system will say, hey. I know
all of these prefixes, 123Dot0Slash24,
and it keeps the traffic within the autonomous
system.
If there is a prefix that it doesn't
understand, it's going to reach out to its
peers and say, do you know this prefix?
And when those peers come back and say,
oh, yeah. I I'm responsible for this prefix
that will rip the traffic to there, or
it may say, oh, I know someone else
is responsible for this prefix. And it starts
to route the traffic through all of these
autonomous system
until eventually
you get to the server.
And what you want is a company which
has a very intelligent backbone with a good
number of peers where those prefixes could be
resolved and as many not as many. And
as less or little hops
as possible
because the less hops that you do, the
faster or the less the latency will be.
And that's where Equinix comes in. Equinix has
one of probably the most substantial
Internet backbone in the world. I I can't
think of another.
So
and that's because Equinix works with Google,
Amazon,
Cloudflare, all these other people too, I believe.
Don't quote me on that.
You can quote Jeremy on that if he
agrees, but not
I was gonna say, I'm not sure there's
anybody that we don't, but partner
partner team is standing by. Yeah. Equinix is
the Internet. So
they have a good network for this.
So what we're gonna do today is set
up a global IP, which just means it's
an IP address that Equinix will broadcast to
us within all the autonomous systems that they
own and peer with, and we should be
able to see some traffic. Now I know
this is a lot of words,
and I decided to do some diagrams to
try and show how this works.
Now what this diagram assumes is that your
application has a EU server, a US server,
and an Australian server.
And what happens is our clients make requests
in The UK and Germany
to their ISP.
Their ISP
either has their own autonomous system or peers
with other autonomous systems that are already within
the EU
because
our infrastructure providers such as Equinix Medal
is advertising
our prefix
to these autonomous systems, we get directed
we get routed directly
to the EU server.
And the same works within The US. You
can have customers within New York and Los
Angeles who go through their own ISP.
It's likely there's a ton of systems in
New York and Los Angeles,
and they can all route to the same
US server or maybe you're going
full hawk here and you have servers on
the East Coast and the West Coast, and
those will be routed appropriately as well.
And then the same happens for Australia.
Which is one extra example here is that,
you know, Japan,
there may not be you may not run
any infrastructure in the Japan or China or
everything like that, but we still want to
see as few hops as possible to get
it across for that Australian server.
Those diagrams make sense? You happy with that?
I think so. The
and the
the IP address will be the same IP
for all of like, there's one IP that's
then being announced from each announced
from each place.
Right. Is the same Yeah. Yeah. I should
have I should have asked for the diagram.
All clients, we can request for
eight dot eight dot eight dot eight or
one two three four or whatever.
But, yeah, you're right. All these clients are
using the same
IP address to reach different servers around the
world.
Excuse me.
Which is what makes BGP so cool. You
don't have to have overly complicated
DNS setups. You don't need to have well,
in fact, yeah, it would just be DNS
that you've done this any other way,
but that can be rather complex.
Multiplexing,
multicasting, your BGP are a very clean way
to do that.
Alright. And and that's what's called Anycast?
Yeah.
Yeah. Anycast BGP. I I said multiplex, didn't
I? Anycast BGP. There we go.
How does that go wrong? What happens if
so
is the
are each of the servers themselves,
announcing the route to get to them, or
is that something that happens at the provider?
Or
what happens when one of the servers turns
off?
Well, I mean, we can speak from
the Equinix metal perspective, and as we're gonna
show how that works here. So
Oh.
Oh, we we we probably should head to
the lab, but okay.
Well, you know,
it's not anybody can just start
announcing or advertising BGP routes. Right? You
can run your own autonomous system for sure.
But if nobody peers with you,
those routes
don't reach the global network.
This is where Equinix come in. Equinix have
probably one of the best peer networks in
the world, which means if you're able to
advertise your IP address to them, it's gonna
go to hopefully most of the autonomous systems
on the Internet and give you that
quick, fast, low hop routing that you really
want.
But we do see a lot of BGP
attacks on the Internet as well. I don't
know if that's where you were going with
your question, but, you know, people autonomous systems
could
and there's a prefix that they don't actually
or can't actually
and this is usually
when you see has to go down. It's
usually misconfiguration
for BGP. Right? Like,
every time a CDN network like Fastly
or Cloudflare go down, it's
either,
yeah, a typo on their BGP prefix and
the traffic is routed to the to nowhere.
But with Equinix and Equinix metal,
they're tighter controls. They're passwords on the BGP
servers. You can only broadcast global IPs.
I think we just show how it works,
and then hopefully that makes more sense because
I'm just gonna start waffling otherwise.
Nope. That's
that'll work. Alright. So we're gonna move on
to part two.
We're gonna deploy our first servers.
So we're just gonna keep this nice and
simple for today.
Deploy two NGINX servers in two different metros
within the Equinix metal network and configure our
BGP. If you get stuck, there's a video.
Hey. That's this video, which you're probably watching
right now. So
remember to use the code Rawkode for your
credit and start by browsing to the Equinix
middle console
and requesting our first global IP.
So we can do that now.
But from your project,
we go to IPs
and IPs,
request,
and you have two options. You've got your
public IPv4
or the global IPv4.
So it is a bit more expensive, but
it's totally worth it if you wanna keep
that latency down
all around the world, You can select how
many you need. For today, we just need
one.
I'll just put course as a tag
and we'll submit our request.
If those buttons are not Yeah. I
I didn't go.
Yeah. No. I suppose that stands to highlight
definite in in this interface anywhere on the
global being on the right side there. Otherwise,
BGP, you can use locally to inside your
inside a single metro or location to swap
IPs around machines. But if you're looking to
be routable from
outside,
then
Yeah. Gotta go global.
Alright. Let's refresh this page.
And I now have my global IP address.
Now if any of those options are not
there, what you need to do is go
to BGP
and there's a button to enable it here.
I already have it enabled.
But if you don't see the global option,
you have to come here and turn it
on.
Next, we're gonna spin up to servers.
So we're going to use on demand servers.
You know, if you're just playing around, just
pick the smallest instance available within the metro.
You don't need anything
demanding or powerful for this. And just make
sure you deploy Ubuntu
because all the commands below
are for Ubuntu or Debian machine.
All right. So let's do
I'll do Amsterdam.
Ubuntu
and
go.
Got a a favorite region in The US
you would like me to deploy to?
I think the closest is gonna be Dallas.
Dallas. We can do Dallas.
And they've also got c three small
and
go.
Alright. Those will take
two to three minutes. Oh, go back to
server page. There we go. Yep. Those will
take two to three minutes. So we'll
maybe I should have done that at the
start and then went back to the introduction.
That's all good.
So once those come up, we're gonna SSH
onto them. We're gonna run a few commands.
Our goal is we are going to run
NGINX on Dallas machine and the Amsterdam machine,
and we'll run curl request
locally,
which should give us
some simple stats about how long the command
took to open the connection, get the first
pay, etcetera.
We'll also run a trace route so you
can actually see the hops that the request
for my machine takes to get to the
server.
What we what we would expect to see
is that I hit the Amsterdam server. We
can modify the HTML just so that prints
out, hi. I'm Amsterdam and hi. I'm Dallas.
But we should see that always hit the
Amsterdam server.
After that, we'll use
or, I mean, we could curl from the
Dallas machine, but I guess that's not gonna
be very interesting from a written perspective. But
there's a website listed here too
after we get past all this stuff called
loco ping. I have a computer. I'm in
Texas. I'll give it a look. Yeah. Yeah.
We can do it from your machine too
if you're happy to share your screen, but
I I didn't want to assume.
We can also use local ping, which will
show
gives us a web interface to trace route
as well. And I think we can select
the location that it runs from. So, hopefully,
we'd be able to experiment and see where
that
alright. The way that we're configuring BGP today
is through a piece of software called BERT.
This just does does
this handles the BGP advertising
from each of our machines to the top
of rack switches within Equinix metal.
Those can then publish it to the Equinix
network, and then all the written happens and
get spread to the Equinix peers. We should
see this happen really, really quickly.
What also may be cool to do because
I'm trying to go to off script in
our demo today,
is we should be able to shut down
BERT on one of the machines.
And within a minute,
probably quicker,
we'll actually see that our prefix will no
longer be advertised within that region,
and then it will shut down Amsterdam. And
what should happen is I get redirected
to Dallas. So we'll see the latency increase,
but I'm not losing access to the service.
So kinda That's where I was going.
Alright.
Cool. I didn't pick up on that, but
there we go. I'm glad we got there.
I'm glad I got there in the end.
You just need to you'd give me more
heads. That's all.
Alright. Like I said, I never had that
03:00 coffee.
Yeah. Let's let's go see where we are
with these machines.
Alright. We've got one. So we can start
with Amsterdam
First.
We're
hopefully gonna be able to SSH on,
click the button on my watch.
Nice.
Probably just do these at the same time.
We don't really need to configure both, right?
Let's see if they have an IP address
yet.
Yeah.
All right. Won't be able to SSH just
yet, I don't think.
But I yeah. I'll wait till I'm on
it and then I can broadcast my input
to both. Nobody wants to see me input
and solve these things twice.
Let's see. How far are we?
It could be another minute.
Okay. We'll just start. I will do it
twice.
Maybe the first couple of Oh, that'll allow
you to that'll
allow you to make the do a quick
twiddle of a
so you don't have to change both of
the
NGINX hello pages. You'd only have to change
one of them.
Because if the other one was the default,
then you'd know.
Yeah. Sure.
Okay.
So
at update
and then after install BERT and NGINX, we're
going to install one more package. Equinix metal
make this really, really easy for us. I
don't know why I've not got the link.
I'll need to add that. I'll edit that
after.
So the network help us or an open
source repository on the Equinix GitHub
just in Python scripts that configure BERT for
you using the metadata service.
So you don't even really need to hand
draw your own BERT config, which is pretty
nice.
Alright. Last try before I broadcast my input.
Oh, alright.
Okay. I can zoom in or I can
change my text size.
We're on this profile.
We'll do app install nginx
for
that oh, no. I have to clone the
network helpers, but I do need Python.
So
I'll grab these two back. Yeah. You have
the you have the link down there in
configuring a in the configuring bird section.
Alright. Let's just do Python three.
Much better.
The Dallas box is taking a wee bit
extra time.
Cool.
Now we can jump over here
and run this. I'll run through these commands
in a second. Let's just rate the file
first.
And then we'll open this up because we
need to do a small copy or a
small substitution.
So what you have to do with BGP
addresses is bind them to the look back
device on your Linux machine. We have to
paste in our address here, which we're gonna
get from the Equinix page.
Okay. Let's do that there.
So we go to our IP address and
we copy our global one.
And
we drop it in. The netmask is there
and we save. And we should be able
to just run
Come
on, David.
What I get wrong there?
That's my guide.
Cool.
IP ADR.
We have our BGP address. Now you can
just ignore the
the warning errors here. Those are
collateral damage.
But we do have this, which I think
is correct.
But next,
we are gonna use the metadata service to
pull down some peer information.
I'm just gonna copy this.
So
in fact, let's just show how this works.
Alright. So when you're on Equinix metal devices,
you can hit this endpoint.
Can't type.
Did
I spell something wrong? Oh, yeah.
And you get this big massive JSON blob.
Pivot through I don't have JQ.
Pivot through JQ, and you get all this
metadata from the device. This is all your
network information,
but more importantly, it has our BGP information.
So
grep
for peer.
Why does
not work?
It doesn't matter.
Yeah. That's a built in. You there at
the very least.
I'm assuming j q maybe spits out the
text as standard.
No. It doesn't. It was standard though. Yeah.
I don't know. I think it should be
it should be pretty
maybe it be printed. But There's no clear
information here.
So we've missed a step.
Let's make sure BGP is enabled on our
device.
Disabled.
There we go.
So I'll add that to the guide as
well and I'll enable it on our Dallas
server.
Cool. So you have to enable BGP.
And that should be almost instantaneous.
So yep. There we go. So if we
do the JQ Grep again, you'll see that
we have a peer autonomous system ID 65530,
And then our peer IPs are listed as
an array afterwards. And if we take off
the grid, it should still be relatively visible.
Here. There we go. So we've got our
BGP neighbors configuration now.
You can see all of this stuff.
So we've got everything that we need. We
also have access to the server now. So
let's get caught up so that I don't
have to type everything twice.
Update
install.
Yeah.
Get
type
three,
hyphen three,
put.
And
the interface.
Mars has a nice tech to use dash
dash raw with j q. Cool.
Oh, yeah.
That'll work.
Alright.
So we need to drop in our BGP
address again.
All right.
I
think we're in the same place.
So
I'm gonna broadcast
this
to all.
Okay.
Back to my guide. So what are we
doing with that metadata?
I think this command is actually doing much
reset for showing us stuff. So let's just
run that. I don't have to queue another
machine.
The joys. Alright.
Yes. So this curl is just going to
j q and pulling out information that we
need. So we've got IP addresses, autonomous systems,
and we've got the peer IP addresses. These
are the things that we need.
Next we're adding the routes.
So let's
just do the curl first.
So if we paste this, we get a
gateway
that we need to route our traffic through.
And if we run IP route,
think it's handled for us already on these
machines. But sometimes what you'll get with
depending on the metro facility, I can't remember
how this works, maybe even the IPX that
you will have to add that route manually.
But if you see your gateway list is
an IP route table, then you're okay.
So we can skip that step. Next, we
wanna configure birds. So let's just do this
couple commands at a time. We're creating a
directory under opt and cloning our network helper.
We could see the Internet and install our
dependencies.
Hopefully, it just work.
We can run a configure script, which is
also gonna write and show us the failures
in the t command.
Whole bunch of stuff there that configures our
BGP neighbors based on that metadata that we
already seen through the curl j two command.
And next, we can restart
or start BART in this case.
If we run a system CTL status,
we can see that it's running.
And we'll ignore that error, I don't think
that is an issue.
Confirm this works, Bart provides a console where
we can run this command
and
looks good.
We have our address,
the autonomous system,
things should be cool.
Drop it.
All right, testy test time.
Let's modify
var
w.
Is that a thing?
Oh, is on one of them.
Did I I forget NGINX on the first
machine? Oh, no. I'm still in BERT.
Alright.
Then
I need someone to type for me.
HTML.
Oh, no. I don't have it.
Bar.
Oh, there we go. Okay.
Default NGINX page,
and we'll just change the welcome text.
We'll stop the broadcast for a moment.
So this first one is Amsterdam.
The second one is
Dallas.
And then go back to broadcast. Oh, we
don't need to broadcast now because we're we've
done all the
the work as it were.
And
in theory, and I'm a bit nervous to
go running this now,
this should work. Let me open it in
the right profile.
We should be able to do a curl
no. It should be a to our IP
address.
Well,
is it working? No spoilers.
It is working.
Oh, I haven't restarted it today. Oh, no.
I shouldn't have to restart it today. I
get I get welcome to Dallas welcoming me
in 14775408.
Hey. Look at that.
So I am continuously
Amsterdam.
Wow. We may actually finish this stream on
time. I was getting a bit nervous there.
Alright.
Let's run our trace route to our IP
address. I really need to copy that thing.
I'm gonna copy again now because I'll need
a few things.
Alright. Traceroutes can
take a little bit of time, especially as
I go through
my ISP's
network, which does not respond to ICMP pings,
which is what those stars mean.
It slows down the entire traceroute because it's
gonna do it three times before it gives
up.
And I think it's gonna do that a
bunch of times.
Is there a command with traceroute to just
do one thing and give up? I don't
know.
One ping only? I believe so. I I
can't remember what it is offhand. But
Yeah. I'm not oh, yeah. Dash q queries.
Let's try speeding this up then. I'm about
one.
And if that does these stars, I'll be
making you unhappy. Let's set us back a
bit twice sec.
Good. That'll speed up a little bit until
we get outside of my very opaque ISP
five g network.
Has the Trisher are you doing our Trisher
too?
Same.
Alright. I'm
getting about getting about eight and a half
milliseconds over here.
Alright.
I mean, that looks like we hit the
network.
So what's it done there?
I don't know. Alright. 15 hops. You're fight
can you fire off ping first? I I
went ping first, which gave me the
which gave me the
yeah. So 12 hops over here.
Cool. So we got our hops. We can
see the trace route. Actually thought we'd see
some of the
normally, when I wrote a trace route, we
see some of the IPX information. Like, oh,
you've hit Dallas and you've gone through this
metro facility.
But not today, but that's okay.
But we got nice little ping,
and it
works.
So
before I go shutting down
barge
on
Amsterdam,
let's try
locaping
and see what this gives us.
Cool. So we can drop in our IP
address and let's hit this from
somewhere that might be yeah. I don't know
where Singapore or Hong Kong will route to.
Oh, this isn't gonna show us the HTML.
So who knows?
Oh, no. We we can see.
It gives us country information.
Is it finished?
Yeah, went to Dallas. There we go.
Although it's in New York, but I assume
Dallas.
All right.
Let's try that again from France.
See if it's different.
Oh, it's doing it from both. Oh, that's
cool.
Well, we hit Dallas again over here.
It looks like the one on the right
is finished.
Alright. Let's enable a few more. Screw it.
Spain,
Italy,
Netherlands,
USA.
Cool.
Right. So Dallas at Dallas really quickly. Amsterdam
is in America.
Interesting.
Oh, they're all going there. Oh, no. Except
Milan went to.
Yeah.
Maybe that website works. I'm not sure.
Let's do another test.
Let's shut down bird.
Stop.
Let's shut down NGINX too.
But we should have nothing
run-in here.
And if we do a curl,
I have Dallas.
I was just making more things go Yeah.
The
I was trying to I was trying to
figure out exactly what would happen,
then if it would immediately,
fail over and send you to the, the
correct one or if any, any additional intervention
would be required.
No. No intervention should be required because when
Bart stops advertising,
the autonomous system in that region will just
drop the prefix.
It's really quick. I remember Dan doing some
tests with his open source project
Oh. KubePit.
Oh. I think he said he got it
he said it was, like, three seconds for
the failover and the prefix to be dropped.
So it's it's super fast.
And the fact that I could just curl
and even though it's a bit longer
to Dallas,
you know, we're seeing the hundred and thirty
two milliseconds ping instead of the thirty milliseconds
ping. At least I'm still getting a service.
So
what we're seeing is BGP is great for
globally written traffic
to your customers, at least to a data
center or server as close to your customers
as possible.
But as a happy side effect of this,
should you happen to lose any of those
advertisements,
the global network can reroute you to somewhere
else.
Maybe a good experiment for this if we
ever do a rerecord of the first part
would be to do three or four servers
and shut them down strategically
to see where I'm gonna be routed through.
But I think for today, this is a
success.
So
we'll jump back. It should go like, it
should continuously go from wherever you are to
next fastest or fewest or fewest tops. But,
yeah, it'll be a
yeah. It'll be a you know, fun experiment.
Yeah. If I can't be routed to Amsterdam,
I would like they route me to Germany
if I had one there.
If there was nothing in Germany, maybe it
would go to the next yeah. The the
the network handles this for you, especially this
is why it's important to be in a
network like Equinix where they have these peers.
They have the backbone,
and the intelligent written should be there for
you.
I hope people find us useful.
Feel free to jump on the Discord if
you need any support, advice, or questions.
Thank you, Jeremy, for joining me today. We've
got one minute left. Any last words?
Absolutely.
Thanks for
absolutely.
Thanks for having me, and I look forward
to
the the following portions of the following portions
of the course.
Yep. The next part of this course will
be back next week. We're going to deploy
core DNS globally
using the same setup. We're gonna do this
three times with three different pieces of software
just to show you why it's important, how
to keep those lenses down, and scale with
your customers. So tune in then. We'll see
you all soon. And thanks again, Jeremy. I'll
catch you in a bit. Absolutely.
Bye.